alright guys we've got a bunch to get
into here with uh with Zack thank you
for coming thanks for having me
absolutely alright so let's do this
a real quick background kind of how you
get to getting into crypto sure so I've
worked at venture-backed tech companies
for a while most recently in the FinTech
sector and I heard about Bitcoin at a at
a meet-up or some type of event
basically as an investment tip this is
2015 somebody was like hey it's come
down from a thousand it's gonna change
the world you should buy some so I
downloaded the coin base app bought a
little bit of Bitcoin it was around
three hundred dollars at the time a
month later it went up to 450 and I was
like you're a genius and I sold it and
now that was it that was it for you know
another few months and then it went
higher up to 700 I'm like you're an
idiot I bought back in I started getting
really really just personally interested
and intellectually curious about what
was going on with Bitcoin with
blockchain I learned about etherium in
early 2016 it was fortunate to you know
invest in that project pretty early and
at a certain point my girlfriend my
girlfriend said you need to stop talking
to me about this because you're talking
about it all the time and I'm not that
into it so I started going to meetups
and here in New York City and I watched
the crowd at these meetups changed from
being computer scientists and kind of
that super early anarchist type Bitcoin
adopters to some venture capitalists
more entrepreneurs some Wall Street guys
especially around the time early last
year when the enterprise aetherium
Alliance got announced and at a certain
point I just you know decided that I
needed to get involved and then I had an
experience with the bank which was
basically a light bulb moment for block
5 where they were not happy that I
listed Bitcoin and ether on a on a
financial statement that I submitted to
them and and so you know here we are
absolutely and so as you're going to the
meetups and all that stuff we walk
through kind of the FinTech experience
right but it's a pre crypto what were
some of the things that you were
interested in working on yeah so I was
working in the online lending industry
and there's a couple of really
interesting parallels from the online
lending industry into what's happening
in the crew
world I started in the online industry
pretty early in its incarnation which is
kind of 2011 2010 to 2012 and the
thinking at that time was this is gonna
overtake the bank's peer-to-peer lending
is the way the economy is going to be
driven this is coming out of the
financial crisis and we're gonna
completely disrupt the world every
conference was sold out everybody was
just so pumped and the industry shifted
over time first it switched from being
peer-to-peer to being primarily
institutionally funded so this whole you
know screw goldman sachs idea went out
the window as who as soon as goldman was
willing to write a check to these
companies and and fund their business
and also it didn't overtake the banks it
didn't completely change the financial
system but it did add to the financial
system we're now today you have I
believe it's around thirty five percent
of all the consumer loans that are
originated in the u.s. coming from
online lending businesses so it was
complimentary and it shifted from being
peer-to-peer in retail focused in to
still having a bit of that peer-to-peer
component but being primarily backed by
institutional investors of different
types and I worked at two different
companies in that sector the first was a
company that was basically in the middle
of the ecosystem it was called orchard
we had a broker dealer an RIAA and ATS
data products technology products and we
worked with all the biggest lenders so
Lending Club sofa prosper funding circle
and in the institutional investors that
were buying the loans or lending to the
platforms and then after orchard I
worked at a consumer lender called CB
which had a point-of-sale customer
acquisition strategy similar to like
PayPal credit got it fascinating stuff
okay alright and so as you kind of are
having that FinTech experience you're
going to the Bitcoin meetups here in New
York City etc you eventually start a
company block fie right why start the
company what was kind of the original
idea the original idea was mmm-hmm for
all the same reasons that the online
lending industry was successful which
were there are areas of the lending and
debt markets where banks are not
participating I thought that the crypto
ecosystem was going to need debt and
credit products just like every other
ass
class and that banks weren't going to do
it all so I felt like just in terms of
my you know career I had been really
early at a few startups but never a
founder but I was ready to kind of take
that leap and start a company myself got
it very very cool
alright so I don't think that very many
people understand what we're talking
about when we talk about lending
especially in the crypto space so let's
go kind of through the lending 101 right
so asset back lending describe kind of
how this works in crypto in terms of
what is the collateral what is the loans
what you know LTV etc sure so first I
think it's helpful to understand the
different types of lending that are
taking place in the ecosystem and I
broadly think of them as happening in
four different buckets so the first
bucket which is what block Phi does is
lending USD backed by your crypto so you
have Bitcoin you don't want to sell it
you can borrow USD backed by the value
of your Bitcoin the second type is
lending Bitcoin which is primarily for
the purpose of initiating a short
position so I want to borrow Bitcoin
have a liability denominated in Bitcoin
which means I have a short position the
third type is on exchange lending so
basically facilitating margin trading
within a centralized ecosystem and the
last one is scams which I think is
important to mention because they are
out there and if you ever see anything
that you know is 1% interest a day or
something crazy like that it's probably
a scam and you should run away block 5
operates in that first bucket so being
able to borrow USD backed by your
Bitcoin or ether which are the two
assets we support now and the way it
works is very similar to a home equity
line of credit or a securities back loan
so let's say you have ten thousand
dollars worth of Bitcoin today with
block value could borrow up to thirty
five percent of that value in USD so you
post your Bitcoin as collateral we wired
thirty five hundred dollars to your bank
account and then you make monthly
interest only payments throughout the
duration of the term with a bullet of
principal or the option to refinance at
the end got it in so right now you guys
are doing 35 percent LTV or less right
and then what's that term life look like
so right now we're going out to
a one-year term and there's no
prepayment penalty so a lot of our
clients use it for shorter durations the
reason it's a one-year term is is
twofold first it's more attractive to
institutional counterparties who want to
finance these assets to have a shorter
duration second we think that for our
customers benefit costs and interest
rates are going to come down
dramatically over time for this type of
borrowing probably pretty quickly and so
locking yourself into a three-year
five-year you know ten-year duration
type loan at current rates isn't the
best thing got it okay and so when
somebody posts collateral what they're
doing is they're they're over
collateralizing the loan right so if
I've got that $10,000 I'm giving you
$10,000 worth of Bitcoin you're giving
me a $3,500 loan where does my $10,000
of Bitcoin get so so right now we are
custody in via a partnership with Gemini
so we leverage their custody solution
which is you know highly regulated never
been hacked used by lots of different
institutional investors they've got a
cold storage set up where you know 95 or
more percent of the assets at any point
in time are kept in cold storage so we
felt like it was better for us to
partner there versus build and we
custody all of our assets with them
currently got it and so as I give you my
$10,000 or the Bitcoin you've given me
that loan you put my assets into Gemini
with the storage partnership walk
through how you're managing the margin
and actually even what that means right
so how you actually are de-risking it
from your end
we as that collateral is sitting in
storage I'm sure so this type of lending
is very it's not very risky at all from
a lender's perspective there are some
decisions that need to be made from our
client's perspective in terms of whether
these products are right for them but
the way it works is so you have ten
thousand dollars worth of Bitcoin we
Lynch you thirty five hundred USD if the
price of Bitcoin drops fifty percent and
the Bitcoin is now worth five thousand
USD we have a margin call
what happens in a margin call is there's
a 72-hour window where you can either
add more Bitcoin as collateral pay down
the loan in USD or take no action if you
take no action and then at the end of 72
hours your loan to value ratios is still
above that trigger level we will
initiate a partial collateral sale and
when we initiate a partial collateral
sale we basically take all the proceeds
to pay down the loan rebalance the LTV
ratio got it and so that 70 percent LTV
is a trigger right from a margin
standpoint so if I've posted my $10,000
all of a sudden I go from a 35% LTV to a
70% you go ahead and give me that 72
hour margin call window if the price of
Bitcoin recovers and I get out of that
70 percent LTV how is that handled
you know we're communicating with our
clients in an automated basis and also
via phone calls at every step along the
way but the way it's handled is you
wouldn't need to do anything you would
get a notification saying oh the price
has moved up to X your LTV is now X and
you're no longer in the margin control
got it okay and so when you go to
actually have that partial liquidation
right to kind of relieve that the the
margin there are you guys doing this on
exchanges through OTC like walk me
through kind of you you've managed the
margin right and now you're in a
position where somebody's taking no
action and you've got to actually do
that partial sale how do you actually
execute that so we fully automated all
of the process from customer and
communication to margin called issuance
to liquidation if needed at the end of
the 72-hour window and we do it on
exchanges currently we like to be
connected to places where we can trade
24/7 real time via an API but over time
that might evolve a little bit as our
portfolio gets larger we might start
working with OTC desks we might start
looking at different ways that we can
hedge and lock in large amounts of
liquidity if we needed it ahead of
or at the time where we where we need to
initiate partial collateral liquidations
but in practice so far even through a
bear market so we've been lending since
January most of our clients are curing
their margin calls so what we found is
that while we have this you know fully
automated robust risk management system
that can sell collateral if needed it
hasn't had to happen in practice that
much most of our clients are responsive
they're either paying off their loan
we're telling us ahead of time hey sell
a little bit and pay off the loan or
adding more collateral so while we have
had a high rate of customer
notifications we've had a very low rate
of margin call initiations and and an
incredibly low rate of partial
collateral sales got it and so let's
talk about kind of the psychology of a
crypto borrower right so I've got crypto
I posted as collateral you're giving me
a USD loan why am i doing that so this
is primarily a wealth management product
and if you look at traditional markets
some of the types of individuals that
typically use products like this to
borrow against securities for example
are optimizing for asset diversification
and they're optimizing for tax costs and
what that means is that the majority of
our clients are using the proceeds from
the loan to invest in things frequently
that's that's real estate related but
they're using it to you know optimize
their personal financial situation in
some cases it's paying down debt but
more frequently it's it's purchasing
other assets and the tax benefits are
that if you've owned Bitcoin for a long
time and you have an embedded capital
gain by not selling you're delaying that
taxable event of incurring that capital
gains tax event also if you use the
proceeds of the loan to invest in
something you're eligible for the
investment interest expense deduction
which basically means you can deduct the
interest cost from other investment
income or capital gains in the same tax
period got it and so are these
businesses taking these loans are they
individuals like you know who who is
actually you know kind of pursuing these
loans it's both so we've we've done
loans as low as $2,000
to individuals and we've we've done
loans as high as you know seven figures
to high net worth individuals or
businesses on the business side it's
more frequently a kind of balance sheet
optimization and op X optimization so
you have a lot of ether on your balance
sheet you don't want to sell at current
prices but you have liabilities in USD
this can be a tool to help cover those
liabilities while maintaining your ether
position for example got it that makes
sense okay and then let's walk through
the difference of you know you guys're
operate in that first bucket where
people are you know borrowing USD
against crypto collateral
walk me through kind of the other two
buckets cams are self-explanatory but
but let's go into you know when people
are either borrowing Bitcoin or that
third bucket yeah so in the borrowing
Bitcoin bucket companies like Genesis
capital have done a really good job of
enabling that it's a kind of critical
market function to be able to borrow
these assets there's really two use
cases one is if you're trading you want
the ability to go short and the other is
if you have liquidity needs denominated
in crypto so you're facilitating trades
or your business takes payments in
crypto and you don't want to hold the
volatility risk of those assets on your
balance sheet if you borrow them rather
than just hold them it's it's a kind of
better way to manage risk so typically
it's collateralized by USD in some cases
it's not so if you want a short Bitcoin
let's say you need $100,000 with a
Bitcoin to go short you'll have to post
you know maybe 120,000 USD and then the
interest works the same way that it
works on the USD borrowing set got it in
the thought process there is the
psychology is very similar right
basically I have an asset and I need a
different asset I don't want to actually
just outright purchase it I just want to
borrow it for some predetermined amount
of time and so whether you're using US
dollars to get access to crypto or using
crypto to get access to US dollars it's
a very similar mechanism it's just the
individual needs are a little different
similar a similar mechanism but the
but the use case is completely different
when you're borrowing UST backed by
Bitcoin you have a long Bitcoin position
that you want to maintain when you're
borrowing Bitcoin backed by USD you're
bearish and you want a short Bitcoin yep
makes sense
all right so let's zoom out here in
Tucker out just crypto in general all
right
what's going on with kind of Bitcoin in
the prices The Wall Street you know kind
of banks all looking at this how does
all this play into you know you guys is
a financial service in the crypto space
so our addressable market is ultimately
a derivative of the total crypto market
cap so we are Bulls by design of our
business and we want the ecosystem to
grow my personal view is that everything
that happens whether it's on the
regulatory front in terms of adoption or
on the institutional investment front or
with new institutional type structures
being created like the backed program
all that is very very good the more this
ecosystem gets connected to the
traditional financial ecosystem the
stronger it is long term and the I think
bigger the market will get long term as
a as a result so you know my personal
view is that we're still just in kind of
a blow off period I think we are seeing
a decoupling of Bitcoin from other
assets I think that trend will probably
continue at least for a little while and
I think that a year to year three years
from now I don't know the exact
timeframe but we'll be looking at you
know half a trillion to a trillion
dollar market cap some somewhere in that
window got it and and do you think that
Wall Street just looks at this as
another asset class do you think that
they are looking at this as you know
everything's gonna be tokenized or where
do you really think they see it reca
script it was pretty obvious crypto
wants the validation sophistication and
kind of sustainability that Wall Street
brings right you she's in the ETF you
see this in the bank's coming in etc but
flipping the table around how did the
bank's actually look at crypto I think
the vast majority of them are still
scratching their heads and not really
looking at it some of the
fast movers understand it probably a lot
more than they get credit for I think
they're looking at Bitcoin as a digital
gold use case I think they're looking at
blockchain technology as as potentially
something that they can get value out of
but more so right now kind of a good way
to do innovation theater within their
innovation labs and say oh we did a
blockchain trial of something and it's
great but we're not actually going to
use it I don't think they are thinking
too much about tokenized securities and
they're certainly not thinking too much
about you know the utility token model
or anything further downstream I think
they understand it I just don't think
it's it's top of mind relative to crypto
I think they're thinking about Bitcoin
and there may be thinking about what
types of products they can create in
general for the asset class that will be
relevant for their clients got it I've
never heard an innovation theater before
it's pretty good all right so let's go
kind of further in the took my security
side so if you think of Bitcoin right it
is a tokenizer or a digital currency
right and so there's four asset classes
you can own stocks bonds currencies
commodities obviously bitcoin is a
version of a tokenized or digital
currency tokenize securities you know
kind of in general are just the stocks
the bond the commodities accessor that
could be tokenized how does that play
out from the lens of lending right is
that something that you know eventually
a lot of these lending businesses will
be able to use as collateral or is it a
similar mechanism you know what do you
guys think they're so so we think that
that we may become an issuer of fixed
income type tokenized securities so
think of being able to get exposure to
the cash flows that are produced from
the lending activities that block Phi
does you know via a fund that that maybe
is tokenized
we see that as being a product that will
be a valuable diversification for us
over time on our platform it's not a
near-term priority but we're kind of
watching how liquidity and structures
and fundraising evolves in the token
high-security market pretty closely
as it relates to other tokenized
securities
I come from this world where you know
there were all different types of
crowdfunding companies and I actually
think that access in markets like the
u.s. is really really strong what I
think is interesting is how do you give
access to people in other markets and it
could even be to the most traditional
investments out there like an SMP 500
ETF can tokenization facilitate someone
in a market as a retail investor who
isn't able to buy that ETF right now to
be able to purchase it I think that use
case rather than the you know let's
tokenize an asset that doesn't have a
lot of demand in the traditional world
is is stronger than you know let's
tokenize an apartment in Brooklyn
like people can people can get exposure
to that right now how do you bring
something that people don't have
exposure to today
into the market and those are the areas
that I think will be the biggest got it
and so as you think about lending
against these tokenize securities right
I think it remains to be seen how liquid
those markets are how you know quickly
they develop is the infrastructure there
etc today you guys only lend against
Bitcoin in aetherium there's obviously
you know a thousand plus other digital
assets why not lend against those from a
risk modeling perspective we can look at
everything the biggest inputs to our
risk models are liquidity and that's by
far the most important and then
volatility as a close second so if
there's not liquidity and I mean at
least you know a hundred million two
hundred and fifty million of daily
traded volume against the USD pair it's
just not big enough we're also still in
the process of getting our name out
there and capturing the you know largely
untapped market for what we're doing
with Bitcoin and ether right now we have
plenty of wood to chop in that regard
for securities specifically there's a
different set of regs that will need to
comply with at least in the US market so
there'll be a bit of work to do there
that becomes an attractive opportunity
but it's something we're following
closely and we don't view ourselves as a
you know lender against a single asset
or a handful of assets over time it's
just a question of how quickly the
market evolves and then we'll be right
there with it got it and then you know
talking about attracting users or
borrowers right where are you seeing the
demand from today and kind of how do you
see that evolving you know over the next
seat let's call 24 months so we're
seeing most of our demand coming largely
from word-of-mouth so existing clients
that have used our product are going to
their friends their network and saying I
worked with block 5 this is what I did
it was fantastic you should you should
try it out we also see a lot of repeat
business from from existing clients but
our longer-term plan is to generate as
much customer acquisition via integrated
partnerships as we possibly can so think
of keeping your crypto in custody with
with whatever custody provider you're
working with now but being able to
access liquidity in the form of a block
file owned via that same interface that
you're used to used to using whether
it's an exchange or a wallet so that's
going to be a big focus for us and
initiating those partnerships over the
next 6 to 12 months it's interesting you
say this because I actually wrote
recently about you know Goldman
everyone's talking about you know as
Goldman gonna trade or they're not gonna
trade and all these rumors are flying
around and I said you know one of the
key things for any Wall Street bank is
getting the custody solution so if you a
proprietary custody solution you can
offer that to your clients especially
kind of a younger demographic of
investors you have a unusually high
percentage of their net worth in these
digital assets it's just like a retail
bank trying to force consumers to get a
bank account right once they get you to
get the bank account then they can
basically sell you all the other
financial services and the switching
cost is actually pretty hot right the
problem is the regulators so there are
you know at least a handful of record at
least a handful of regulators that would
want to nod their heads and approve
Goldman custody in Bitcoin
that's just not gonna happen anytime
soon why not it doesn't happen that
quickly they're not they're not
comfortable enough today to say yeah
fully signed off we understand how
you're gonna do it we think it's safe we
think it's something that should be out
in the market it just things just don't
move that quickly this we have to
remember that this really wasn't on
people's radar until q4 of last year and
decision cycles whether it's from big
institutional investors or especially
from regulators don't move on that fast
of a timeline the CFTC is kind of unique
you know they've got this kind of
gun-slinging chicago vibe which which is
which is incredible but different parts
of the market on the institutional
investment side and certainly on the
regulatory side just they don't move
that quickly mm-hmm well in obviously
the regulators are different than the
institutional investors right so the
regulators have kind of a you know
somewhat fiduciary duty or a mandate to
protect the markets and protect
investors etc on the institutional
investor side they're more making
decisions for themselves right so they
don't necessarily have any sort of
mandate to protect other investors
protect the market and so it's a more
internal decision what it depends what
kind okay
so you've seen that the first movers who
would fall under the institutional
investor category in this space have
primarily been family offices and
proprietary trading firms and the reason
for that is that it's not other people's
money mm-hmm family office it's a
family's money we can be pretty quick
and nimble proprietary trading firm it's
our own capital we trade with it
regulatory you know we're both kind of
light-touch asset management models but
hedge funds and other types of
structures where it's other people's
money have a completely different set of
considerations and also a kind of higher
threshold because they have to believe
it a bigger investment committee has to
believe it and then their investors have
to believe it because otherwise they'll
you know lose the assets that they're
managing or potentially lose their jobs
so I think you'll see a progression
from family offices and proprietary
trading firms to more asset management
groups over the next 6 to 12 months also
getting involved in the space absolutely
and what about the endowments pensions
foundations sovereign well it's like you
know the I think kind of the the middle
ground right so you've got the family
offices proprietary traders who you know
are relatively small in size in general
and then on the other the spectrum
you've got the large banks that have you
know multiple billions or trillions of
dollars of assets but in the middle
there you've got you know those
endowments pensions foundations etc
what's kind of a general sense that
you're seeing their endowments and
pensions and foundations I think are on
the slower moving side sovereign wealth
I think it depends on which sovereign
wealth group here which sovereign wealth
group you're talking about I don't have
a ton of exposure to that market at all
I primarily worked with family offices
banks specifically asset managers on the
creditor alternatives
side of the world so I don't think I
have a qualified opinion to say how long
that would take and I haven't talked
with any of them to have a strong POV
but they'll probably invest through a
fund so you know if you're raising
assets in a in a you know typical fund
structure that's probably part of your
addressable market and I'm confident
that you know some of the asset managers
in the crypto world will make you know
strong progress there as well absolutely
okay all right so let's go to kind of
some quickfire questions here what is
the most controversial thing that you
believe in in crypto space that a high
percentage of other people would
disagree with I think the US dollar is
gonna be the strongest or most liquid
tokenized asset and the entire crypto
ecosystem at some point over the next 12
to 24 months
okay so I'll caveat this next question
so the u.s. dollar right up until
whatever the 50 60 70 s whatever it was
was a hundred percent paper notes right
and today it is 92% non paper right and
so I always joke around I say it was the
first digital currency right what
you're saying here is that we will
actually have a tokenized dollar similar
to a tether true USD etc but it will
become the most liquid why do you think
that I just think that there's a very
strong emerging markets use case that's
bigger than the investment use case for
Bitcoin and if they can get their hands
on a tokenized and trustworthy US dollar
they would probably Halleck eight more
of their capital to that versus Bitcoin
at least in the immediate future I don't
think it comes at the expense of
bitcoins growth I just think that
there's so much demand for that if you
look at stats around things for example
like the amount of US dollar denominated
debt around the world which has only
been available to you know governments
and in large corporations it's over
eleven trillion dollars and retail
investors have never had access to that
before they've never had access to USD
in a lot of places so the ability to
hold USD in the same kind of relatively
private and secure way that you can hold
Bitcoin I think is is huge and and then
from block fives perspective the ability
to get access to dollar-denominated debt
even if you're not a huge government or
a huge corporation is equally huge and
adds so much to the utility value of
Bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies sure
mom Terry policy decisions etc and what
you're saying is today as these
individuals are going into digital
assets mainly Bitcoin where we see with
the kind of transaction volume exchange
volume etc you're saying that they would
in many cases rather go into a stable
store of value like the digitised or
tokenize US dollar rather than Bitcoin
doesn't mean that it's necessary hurts
Bitcoin as much as it's just that's what
actually he's gonna solve the problem on
the ground for those individuals at the
time yeah I mean put yourself in their
shoes what would you want
I mean Bitcoin was down you know 15
percent yesterday 10 percent whatever
the numbers are it's not a knock on the
merits of owning
I'm a huge Bitcoin bull but if you're in
that situation what do you think you
want I would I would absolutely rather
hold the dollar which is not as volatile
mm-hmm and it really what ends up
happening is it furthers this idea of
every stock bond currency commodity
getting tokenized and so you know I
always laugh and you know we permeate
this you know anti US dollar narrative
all time right we look I do it everyone
does it in the crypto space some of it
is just the psychological aspects of the
crypto industry but most people have
almost you know a very high percentage
of their net worth in dollars right it's
not like everyone's just going
immediately into just digital assets and
so you know what you're describing is
almost a halfway point right up hey it's
still dollar denominated or dollar
backed but it is a digital asset that
you can still get all the benefits of
kind of fractionalization and the
movements etc of a digital asset yeah I
mean I think I think we'll see broad
currency market consolidation so I think
currencies that are kind of at the
bottom of the list in terms of size will
get knocked off as a result of you know
the digital asset ecosystem continuing
to grow but when it comes to the dollar
specifically and I have a huge amount of
bias here because I'm you know born and
raised in the US and live here two
things one I think it's really really
scary to think about how a global dollar
unwinding as a reserve currency would
work the global economy runs on the
dollar so a scenario where that happens
and a massive amount of pain and
suffering is not created is one that I
can't envision and the second thing is
that I actually think that the capital
markets system and the system behind the
US dollar is the best thing that the
world has ever seen when it comes to
storing value and creating a currency
maybe it has some unfair advantages
based on our economic situation or oil
being pegged to the dollar and you know
that is what it is but it's the reality
of the situation this is the best thing
the world's ever seen until there's
something better it's not going to get
disrupted in my opinion so all
with you this is the best of worlds ever
seen that doesn't mean that it could be
the best ever right obviously do you
think crypto has the potential to be
better I don't see that right now I do
not see in my lifetime crypto overtaking
the US dollar I will fully admit that
I'm that I could be wrong I see
Bitcoin and other Kryptonian a but I
don't think that 30 years from now we're
gonna say oh bitcoin has a bigger total
market cap than the US dollar I just I
don't see it got it and what do you
think are the obstacles for that
happening where they go like what keeps
you from having the confidence to say
that that will happen well you need you
would need the US government to stand
down and say everybody can pay their
taxes in Bitcoin and we can peg oil to
Bitcoin and you know we're not gonna
we're not going to maintain our military
industrial complex to assert or economic
power over the world anymore got it in
really the government I think the first
step to even getting to that point would
be they've got to say you can pay your
taxes in Bitcoin right so it's not just
saying hey no longer is the US dollar
accept anything like that but they just
gotta accept them as coexisting with
each other and then once you get the
coexistence then you know the market
should determine which is better right
yeah I mean absolutely absolutely I just
I struggle to see it in the US I think
it could happen in other markets I just
struggle to see it in the US and it
scares me a little bit because I don't
think it's a pretty picture no III tend
to agree with you that the world chaos
that would ensue from the unwinding of
the US dollar would be something that
you know for anybody no one could
imagine we actually don't want that we
want in my opinion what we want is for
Bitcoin to have a you know 10 trillion
or whatever the number is market cap and
increase in value dramatically without
creating unnecessary pain and suffering
along the way which is what I think
would happen if the u.s. dollar
collapsed it makes sense
okay so crypto market outside of the
lending space what do you think is the
most interesting company or the most
important company what do I think is the
most interesting company or most
important company outside of the lending
space I think it's either you know buy
an answer her coinbase I mean it's got
to be her actually bit max really okay
all right so explain the logic behind
these bit max has the most Bitcoin
liquidity on a daily basis and it's
still going up they're breaking records
in terms of volume even in a bear market
and they are thinking about some of the
most sophisticated concepts in terms of
enabling further financialization of
these assets which i view is being
important and valuable to the ecosystem
well explained with some of those you
know kind of the financialization what
that means and kind of how they're
thinking about it from your perspective
yeah so you know they're thinking about
creating different types of markets
they're thinking about creating better
connectivity into different types of
fiat currencies just just different
types of structures I don't want to
reveal more than I then I should based
on conversations but they're just really
really smart and they are aggressively
pushing the ball forward and I get
really excited about what they're doing
got it it makes it makes a lot of sense
okay and so let's talk about regulation
for a second so we're you're doing in
the right in the lending space
relatively well understood from a
regulatory standpoint where do you think
the biggest question marks lie in the
regulation uncertainty and you know
hopefully if they get cured then these
institutional investors acceptor get
more comfortable where the question
marks right now that they you're really
focused on I don't think there's I don't
think there's too many question marks
for Bitcoin I think it was great that he
theum you know from the SEC perspective
was labeled not a security
I think the question marks are more and
other markets outside the US China India
how friendly versus unfriendly are these
different countries going to ultimately
become for you know crypto asset trading
but I actually think the US has done a
really good job so far of not stifling
innovation while trying to stamp out you
know really bad activity in fraud
biggest regulatory question mark that
probably exists is rippable security but
for the entire market I don't think
there's there's too much stuff that's
threatening from a u.s. perspective at
this point yeah it's funny bring up
purple because I think that there's
really heated opinions on both sides
right and people will kind of dig their
heels in on that one specifically
without you can reveal your opinion or
you don't have to but walk us through
kind of why like what is the question
mark around rippled being US security
right so kind of what's the argument for
and against it in terms of of that one
yeah I mean I don't even want to go down
that rabbit hole the question mark is
just you know is the SEC going to call
ripple of security or not and smart man
smart man okay so on the lending side
the last question I have for you is
today most of the lending seems like
it's coming from domestically how does
it play out in terms of lending
internationally right how does this
evolved over you know let's say next
2436 months and how does that impact
what you guys are doing a block fine
yeah so a great question
we are just focused on the US market
today but we're already seeing with with
zero marketing around 40 percent of the
traffic to our website and applications
for loans coming from outside the US as
a result we kind of moved up
international expansion on our roadmap
from us what you'll see first is the
availability of international loans to
corporations and then second targeted
expansion into different international
markets for consumers some of the things
we have to think about there is like
where we're going to take
approach like we did in the US fully
buttoned up compliant with every single
different regulation and fully licensed
versus a more uber esque approach and
that probably correlates with how
developed the laws and regulations are
in different markets so in the UK we're
gonna be fully licensed in in other
markets we we may not be fully licensed
there may not be a licensing scheme that
we could you know effectively put
ourselves into but you'll see us
actively lending USD in a tokenized form
outside the US definitely before the end
of 2019 probably in the first half of
2019 got it's fascinating and you know
another thing that I've been thinking a
lot about so you can tokenize assets
themselves right but now we're starting
to seeing a lot of these tokenized funds
right so we've had a sponsor block a
state that basically a real estate
tokenized fund right if I'm an LP in a
fund so basically my LP interest is held
by a digital token Rises my equity in
the fund is that digital token is there
a difference between holding let's say
equity in a real estate building versus
equity in the fund and from a lending
perspective it's the same mechanism with
digital asset but how do you think about
underwriting risk right so not just the
the LP interest in a fund but across all
these asset classes how do you actually
underwrite that risk well there's
definitely a lot of differences there so
an LP interest in a fund is a lot
different than direct ownership of a
building and it's gonna be on a
case-by-case basis in terms of you know
how that fund is structured whether or
not it's diversified what redemption
rights you have what lockup periods
there are how much demand there is from
external investors to participate in the
fund so it's a bit case-by-case one of
the things I would I would just
reiterate from earlier though is that
you know as someone who invests in real
estate directly and also on different
crowdfunding platforms like Realty
shares and fund rise here in the US I
think it's way more interesting if you
can't organize something that I don't
have access to now I can buy
my portfolio of commercial real estate
in the US I can buy individual homes and
different markets you know what I can't
buy well and one of the things here in
the u.s. is that different markets have
different cash on cash returns and
internationally that's that's probably
also true oh you're taking some FX risk
but I think what's more interesting is
how do you give emerging market
investors exposure to the same assets
that US investors have exposure to
already and how do you give us investors
exposure to assets outside the US that
they don't have access to easily today
absolutely so it's a question of like
who's your audience for sure who's your
audience and how is what you're giving
them different than what they already
have access to today for sure
all right so actual last question now is
a lending market encrypted today what's
the biggest challenges that that are
going to kind of present themselves over
next twelve months I think it's uh it's
just awareness you know everywhere we go
every podcast I'm on we hear a lot of
people say we didn't know this existed
and I think that you know companies like
block five who are doing things the
right way institutionally backed really
you know professional teams and
invaluable products coming into the
market as more and more people
understand that they exist understand
that they can get access to them and
that access is easy and it's really
friendly from from a customer and client
perspective the overall ecosystem gets
stronger and more utility value is
created for crypto assets as a result it
makes sense all right so everybody gets
asking me one question at the end what a
question do you have yeah so my question
for you is why are the haters wrong I
followed you on Twitter for a little
while I'm a fan but some people aren't
why are they wrong what are they missing
so I think that there's two things one
is there's a lot of people who don't
they have no clue what we're doing in no
clue how we see the world
and then I think - is anybody who gets a
large audience has a larger voice
immediately attracts both people who are
excited and who aren't excited right and
so one of the things that kind of cracks
us up a lot of times is we can do
something that asset managers have done
for the last thirty years
right I mean literally exact you know
distribute research whatever it is and
we will have people who say you know
this is incredibly helpful thank you so
much for for doing this we will have you
know our clientele who will say you know
I've been looking for information like
this this is fantastic and then we'll
have people say you guys are scam
artists right and so you know I think
that I used to worry about that and kind
of engage with it and kind of you know
you just why why do you have this
negative reaction you try to explain it
all stuff now I'm just looking knock
yourself out I hope you have a great day
right and so I think that the you know
are they wrong right I actually have a
unique opinion in that given the
information that they have given the
perspective that they're looking at that
information through they actually
believe that they're right right and so
if I was sitting in their seat and I had
the information that they had and I had
their perspective I probably would think
the same thing but I think that you know
it's it's once you get all the details
once you get all the information right
and then you realize oh this is actually
what's going on I think they would
change their mind it really comes down
to less about them being right and wrong
and more about you know who is that
target market and is it worth our time
energy and resources to try to educate
you know kind of the anonymous accounts
on Twitter we're going and you know go
to work for our clients right so I think
that that's really where crypto is
unique in that it is so public and it is
such like an open form engagement model
that what used to be said from you know
somebody turning to somebody in their
family sitting on a couch watching
television saying oh you know this guy's
an idiot it's now said publicly and then
they find the other people who say oh
they this guy is an idiot and they all
you know kind of kind of coordinated on
the internet knock themselves out right
and here's another saying that I really
like to go back to I mean first off I'm
a big supporter I think you should you
know absolutely keep it up if people
aren't hating it's because you're not
doing anything
I only hate on people who are doing
something then and you're making stuff
happen and that's cool
listen I am the one that that actually
cracks me up right is uh is the index
fund so we launched this index fund and
you know we basically had institutional
clients calling us saying hey I want to
get exposure to the market I kind of
understand it I kind of don't it was
best performing asset class last year
I've got no exposure help me get off
zero get you know ten basis points of
exposure here and you know should I buy
Bitcoin or aetherium or something else
and and our answer is but we actually
don't think that from a fiduciary
standpoint we can tell you which stock
to pick right and so if you look at the
data well if we index kind of large cap
you know Kryptos market weighted
rebalance you know periodically that's
gonna be the best way for you to get
just kind of beta exposure them so we
went out we found the you know bitwise
and you know think that they're you know
kind of the leader in the crypt of
indexing side and so we create this
index and and you know we did some
things around trying to reduce risk so
we took out any tokens that had the
centralized you know too much
centralization and all stuff and we
announce it again 99% of people
extremely excited that we're gonna go
get a bunch of institutional investors
start owning the asset and paying
attention and learning getting exposure
and all stuff and there's that 1% that
you know you're charging ridiculous fees
you're doing this you're doing you know
you're doing all the stuff and and you
know you start to look at it like
actually when you start looking at how
expensive you know custody is and all
this that like it's actually not a great
business right and so it really is a way
to you know get as much information out
there as you can but also realize you
know who is that target market and and
at some point you just realize you know
the clientele is the focus and the
anonymous trolls on Twitter are gonna
keep trolling no matter what you do so I
just let them go yeah you're raising
money for the ecosystem and that's
that's what's exciting can I do a
shameless plug to wrap this up
absolutely so
I've never let anyone do this before go
ahead I'm honored if you if you go to
block fight calm slash pomp oh and you
take a loan from block five we will add
a hundred dollars of Bitcoin or ethers
here collateral balance block by comm /
pump so does that mean that I'm now
raising additional money for the
ecosystem yes amazing alright man thank
you so much for coming I really
appreciate this as fantastic thanks